What if we could engineer a gigantic mega
structure capable of harvesting every
bit of the sun's energy,
something known as a Dyson sphere?
How long would it take to
construct this mega shell?
Where would we find all the materials
needed and what can we do with the
structure? Once we finally
built it, this is what if,
and here's what would happen if we could
build a Dyson sphere around the sun.
The idea of a Dyson sphere was well
stolen from aliens in 1960 astrophysicist
Freeman Dyson theorized
another civilization that
found a way to meet their ever
increasing energy and space demands.
They rearranged their solar system.
This hypothetical advanced civilization
built a hollow sphere around their own
son and provided themselves with an
incredible amount of energy and habitable
real estate.
But what about us?
How would we go about building this
space level structure? Theoretically,
if we built a Dyson sphere,
we'd have access to a colossal 400
septillion watts of solar energy.
That's a trillion times more power than
our entire civilization consumes today.
The problem is no known material is
strong enough to handle all the space
radiation, and even if we created
one in very large quantities,
a tiny gravitational pull towards
the sun would make our solid sphere
uninhabitable. Not to mention
that it would be totally unstable.
Every meteor strike would push a
part of this fear towards the star,
but all these issues can be
solved with a simple adjustment.
Instead of building a solid Dyson sphere,
we could build a Dyson swarm,
a myriad of solar collectors with
their individual orbits around the sun.
Let's start with a small station,
one that's able to provide
the energy needed for this
whole construction project.
We'd begin on Mercury.
It would become our space,
mine for the iron and oxygen
would need from those elements.
We'd make highly reflective
solar collectors.
The giant mirrors would reflect
light into a small solar power plant.
From there, it would beam the
energy to where we need it.
We'd probably demolished mercury entirely
before we moved on to Venus Mars and
the outer planets,
even nearby asteroids would be decimated.
However,
even just deconstructing mercury would
supply us with enough energy to power up
our super computers and boost
interstellar exploration.
Maybe we'd even built earthlike oases,
large rotating space colonies in the
habitable zone of our solar system.
Maybe if we're lucky,
we'd find other more efficient sources
of energy to help us master space travel,
like artificially generated black holes.
But that's a story for another.
What if.